what was the number-one thing like is it
like because you see a lot of people
that are real fuck-buddies out there and
then next thing you know they're broken
up by you know by Thanksgiving you know
a lot of these things you know
relationships these days it doesn't even
seem to be able to some a lot of kids
are doing seems illegal almost another
couple months in America that should
equal to even you're right man I mean
compared to when I was single
with all these apps and what-have-you it
just seems like yeah people are swiping
meat and you know they screw on the
sidewalk and then they go on to the next
guy yeah girl it's uh it seems like it
seems frightening actually what's going
on out there I don't even know how the
hell people are doing it it's I mean
I've been out of the dating scene for
ten years so I don't even know how I
would even fit into that yeah to give a
go to kind of date that you used to do
back in the day or anything um I love
dating I love him because I love the
hospitality of it a date
I love the actual you're gonna end up
working at the pearly gates who's the
guy they got there now st. Peter you're
gonna hear gonna you're gonna hear that
guy we got a four-top just hold on
no I love going and picking the girl up
yeah
getting in a car surprising her with a
little place that some music now it
would you put music on the car in the
car I'm not not a music guy in the car
I'm not really a music guy yeah but I
love going like she'd go where we going
and that's a little surprise you know I
never really told her look I'd like I'd
find that gum it's a place in Chicago
called pops for champagne I remember
taking a girl's in like 19 and there
downtown to the city like a lot of other
guys were just like they come over let's
go into the movies I'd go on the the
expressway 30-minute drive pull up pops
for champagne that a fake ID sit down
watch a little jazz like I just love the
experience of the actual date yeah going
out and showing a girl a good time
and yeah that's that's kind of that was
my go-to that's what I loved loved to do
I could see that the service that
service industry yeah I'm trying to
think of a good date I took a girl on
one time I think there was some man I
don't know I definitely got a I was
always running around like what's it
look like what's your idea of like like
you're gonna get to know a girl
what do you don't like hey let's go for
caught like what's the what are you
doing probably go for a like a walk like
a local walk probably do I don't know I
don't like you know I don't know if I
like getting to know people that much
you know so I think probably something a
local walk what is that is like opposed
to we're like going somewhere like
getting lost I got like I can't get an
adventurous if I don't have fun you know
rotten clothes I'm not saying I go for a
like a 9 mile walk in one direction bruh
that's really dangerous man so do you
like
that's a good question man do you like
food I mean do you like trying new foods
to found nothing under that you know
what's funny when you said music I never
really got into music that much a lot of
people from your area I know a lot of
those guys are in like you know
wrestling in their backyards and [ __ ]
like that and like um who is that our
Bruce Springsteen probably huh my area
yeah wrestling in yards yeah I feel like
Chicago it's like a place where people
wrestle on their belly do backyard
wrestling and Bruce Springsteen we
didn't we didn't do it we didn't I
didn't I promise cotton we had a lot of
that oh there you go maybe up north or
was Scotty a little of diving off the
roof my mother's from Peoria actually
okay is that where you picked up that
Chicago's is good wrestling Mecca not a
bad Intel
though I grew up in Arlington Heights
there was not a lot of wrestling I was
into wrestling any weren't doing it you
know it's crazy as my sister can't even
read but what does it have to do with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one this one